and start horrible stomach pain after taking a antibiotic a few weeks ago.
Is it possible that inflammation from that could cause this?
Yeah, yes, absolutely. It certainly can. So make sure, okay, so if you take,
so this would be my kind of differential diagnosis, if you take garlic capsules,
and you get horrible stomach pain, good chance you have it also.
Then you, if that's the case, then you want to absolutely make sure you take an HCL or
apple cider vinegar. Look at my post about that. If you can tolerate HCL, you use apple cider
vinegar for a period of time until you've got tolerated. And you get some gut healing products
like slippery elm and deglycerized licorice to help heal the stomach lady.
Pain in your gut after an antibiotic could be two things. It could be pain in the intestinal tract.
So if it's lower down, and you have pain from an antibiotic, it could be damaged to
to the intestinal walls. But you could, on the good side, let's think of good things.
Pain right in the stomach. So right underneath your zyfoid process, the
part of the bone at the end of the sternum done by your stomach. If you have pain right there,
after taking an antibiotic, it actually might be a good pain. You might have HCL or I,
in the antibiotics, will kill H by all right. So since H by all right is a bacteria.
So let's think maybe it was a good thing. However, you get your probiotic could be helpful too.
It certainly didn't order. It should be out of probiotic forever. Anytime you have to take an
antibiotic, take a probiotic with it. And obviously, just whatever you got, just take it. So
um, but I would also get on garlic. If the garlic bothers your stomach, still you got to be,
that's a sign that you could have H by all right. You could have a stomach ulcer.
You do want to do the other things I mentioned, but still want for the vessels, you want to still be
on garlic. So eat some garlic with your food, take garlic with the full stomach.